Why have I had so many jobs?
I get bored easily.
So tell me, why do you want this job?
Why do I want this job?
What do you consider your greatest strength?
My greatest strength is chilling with the coworkers.
You know.
Hold on, just a second.
I don't want to do anything boring.
There's no drug testing here, right?
Man, I hop from job to job.
As soon as it bored me, I'm gone.
Why do I want this job?
It's a good question.
Yeah, I got nothing.
What can I offer?
That's a different...
I could bring sexy back.
Yeah.
That was a good one, right?
That was a good one, right? Yeah.
Yeah.
So, why should we hire you?
I need some extra money to pay off some gambling debt.
Do you really?
Hey, how are you?
Oh! That sounds great.